in this video we'll talk about the
vitamin A deficiency
vitamin A is a fat soluble vitamin which
is very important for normal vision
actually the visual pigment or the
rhodopsin requires the retinal for
optimal function vitamin A deficiency
can cause many symptoms
and that can be classified clinically or
subclinically
is basically a clinical spectrum of
ocular manifestation when vitamin A is
deficient
and this kind of manifestation range
from less severe to more severe forms
on the Lesser severe side of the
spectrum there is night blindness bitot
spot
corneal xerosis and kerato Malaysia is
one of the most severe forms of
xeropthalmia
so let's talk about from the basic first
symptoms of vitamin A deficiency is
actually night blindness or nyctalopia
vitamin A is really important for the
Rod cells which are basically helping us
for low light vision
because vitamin A or retinal is a key
component of the light sensor the
sensitivity of this detector decreases
when you don't have vitamin A and that
is why in low light it's really hard to
understand structures or visualize
so that is happening in case of night
blindness or nyctalopia
so the next one is xerophthalmia so
xerophthalmia is a umbrella term
underneath that there are many character
many kind of like symptoms and
characteristics such as there could be
very severe form known as keratomalacia
where there is keratinus like deposition
on the cornea it's kind of creating a
permanent lesion and it can also lead to
loss of vision there could be also less
severe uh kind of manifestations like
bitot spot which is present on the
sclera
now the symptoms of keratomalacia
includes softness of the cornea opacity
of the cornea and severe infection of
the cornea so the eye would look reddish
and dry dryness of the eye would be
pretty much visible
so the severity of uh kerata malachios
xeropthalmia is different in different
person based on how much the vitamin
deficiency is but these are on the
severe spectrum of the vitamin A
deficiency another thing happens on the
screen is known as phyoderma phrenoderma
simply means frog-like skin so papules
kind of keratogenous papule papules
occurs in the skin and they form
bulge-like structure as shown in the
image
so
this is also known as follicular
hyperkeratosis
vitamin A is really important for skin
cell production or regeneration and also
vitamin A acts like an antioxidant it
has a some to some extent it has
antioxidant like property that's why it
is super in important for screen cell
regeneration and overall physiology of
the skin cells
now just let us finish with appreciating
the overall importance of vitamin A it
has some antioxidant property that's why
it can scavenge Ross it is really
important for skin maintenance and
repair also regeneration of the skin
cells it helps in different type of cell
differentiation especially retinoic acid
is important for different lineages in
the brain while the brain is developing
retinoic acid is really important other
than that it also lowered the risk of
heart attack so I hope we can appreciate
the deficiency of vitamin A and
Associated symptoms if you need more
notes and flashcards follow us on
Instagram or Facebook
support our Channel using super thanks
see you in next video
remember